نظم عشرات المواطنين الاتراك في مدينه
اسطنبول مسيره احتجاجيه لمناصري المحاصرين
في قطاع غزه واحتشد المتظاهرون الذين
سيتوجهون الى امام القنصليه المصريه في
اسطنبول حيث سيطالبون السلطات المصريه
بفتح معبر رفح وادخال المساعدات الانسانيه
والطبيه اللازمه للقطاع وكذلك اخراج
الجرحى عن هذه المسيره معنا من اسطنبول
مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج
عمر
نعم عبد القادر وصلت هذه الحشود الان الى
امام القنصليه المصريه هنا في مدينه
اسطنبول هذه المسيره المظاهره التي انطلقت
بال المقربه من القنصليه انتظرت توافد
الاعداد كبيره حقيقه اعداد ملاحظه هنا
كلها تجمعت كما ترى امام القنصليه المطالب
التي رفعت هنا بالدرجه الاولى هو فتح معبر
رفح بدون قيد او بدون شرط وادخال كافه
المساعدات الانسانيه والطبيه التي يحتاجها
القطاع ايضا تسهيل خروج كل من يريد الخروج
من المصابين والجرحى ومن حتى من ذويهم عبر
مصر وتسهيل دخول الكوادر ايضا الطبيه الى
القطاع طبعا مصر كون هي المتحكمه ب المعبر
هناك بعض ادانات ل اغلاق هذا المعبر من
قبل هنا المتظاهرين ايضا كانت هناك هتافات
شجب وادانه للمواقف الاوروبيه وبعض الدول
التي اوقفت مساعداتها لمنظمه غوث اللاجئ
غوثي وتشغيل لاجئين الاونر وب قرار
المحكمه الدوليه كذلك الامر هناك شعارات
رفعت مناصره لاهالي القطاع وللمحامي
ل لحركه حماس
والمقاومين هناك ادانات بالجمله لسكوت
العالم ما سموه بسكوت وتواطؤ العالم على
ما يحدث في غزه وصمت حيال المجازر التي
ترتكب منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر هذه الجموع
تنتظر حتى يصل كل المتظاهرين الى هذه
الفسحه كما ذكرت بالقرب او امام بالتحديد
امام القنصليه المصريه هنا في في اسطنبول
بعد ذلك سيكون هناك قراءه لبيان من قبل
المنظمين ويتوقع ان يكون هناك مطالبه
مباشره للسلطات المصريه بفتح معبر رفح
بشكل عام
عمر الحاج من اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لك